we're joined now by Peter Mathews
professor of political science at
Cypress College and adjunct professor of
sociology at long beach city college
he's also the author of dollar democracy
with liberty and justice for some how to
reclaim the American dream for all
that's what mr. Trump says he wants to
do do you think mr. Trump's gamble of
avoiding the main debate will pay off I
think it's going to really hurt him a
bit i'll tell you what though he seems
to be a Teflon type candidate it's only
happened in recent history once when
ronald reagan did not show up at the
iowa caucus debate and he lost the
caucus to george w HW bush so this was
not a great move I think that Donald
Trump insulted a lot of people by not
showing up when he's seeking the
presidency of all things and people want
to hear what his ideas are of course he
didn't want to answer any questions to
megan kelly regarding his attitude
toward women which he brought up before
i think there was a double-edged sword
waking he does seem to be making a
career of insulting people and yet his
ratings in the opinion polls are still
extremely high he seems almost
impervious they are the latest polar
I've seen he's eight points out of Ted
Cruz at about thirty-five percent to
twenty seven or so and it has to do with
just a fraction of the Republican Party
keep in mind Republican Party is only
twenty percent of the American
electorate now that's how many
Republicans are register out of all the
voters and out of twenty percent he has
about what thirty-five percent so you
look at do the math on that you'll see
it's a small number of American voters
but still the largest number of
Republicans in such a large field so
that's what's going for mr. Carew mr.
Trump and he wouldn't he won't win the
general election I'm pretty sure about
that but he may win the Republican
nomination that's possible why do you
think that he's got the momentum going
he's got the billions of dollars there's
my book dollar democracy again as not so
much he's asking for other people's
money but he has his own money to
outspend everyone else he even could in
fact today was criticizing Jeb Bush at
his feet at Donald Trump's speech I've
infernos veterans a grouper he's raising
money for them he's criticizing Jeb Bush
for raising 128 million dollars from
other people well Donald Trump not only
raised some money from other people
before in fact in this election but he
actually gave money to other people he
gave my Hillary Clinton and to all of
the other policies on that stage he's
even been proud of saying I have given
money to
of you and you folks did me favors in
the past so that's what dollar democracy
is about and this Republican primary is
going to it's almost a farce but look
let's let's hear the idea is let's see
what happens and I'm looking forward to
seeing what Bernie Sanders and Hillary
Clinton are going to come up with next
debate and in this Iowa caucus for them
because if Bernie wins the caucuses it's
going to be one heck of a campaign and
election season in November Bernie
against Donald o will be something and
even Hillary against on will be
something interesting it just explained
for people who don't understand why the
Iowa caucuses is so important I mean I
where doesn't seem like the most
important state in the United States yes
in Britain as you know you have the
parliamentary system where the election
takes place in one day across the nation
and the party of the majority wins when
they order the majority in parliament
becomes selects the prime minister here
instead it's state by state elections
during the primary and caucus season
Iowa being the first state in the in the
whole lineup lineup gives it a lot of
importance because then it sets a
momentum and each state as it goes
through the caucus or primary it
accumulates more and more delegates for
the candidates on each party and and the
Democratic size proportions entation but
the main thing that will set a trend for
example if if Bernie or Donald win on
onto on the Monday in Iowa the next one
is going to be new hampshire new
hampshire primary which is very
important as well if one of the
candidates wins two in a row it's going
to be a tremendous momentum which will
then get other states to look at these
candidates more carefully and to
reassess whether they should go ahead
and go and donate money to their
campaigns and get behind them and
therefore it's a momentum setting event
i'm talking about Iowa New Hampshire and
then comes don't forget Nevada and South
Carolina for important primary and
caucus States in the month of februari
can make a big difference if these
candidates win three out of four let's
say i'll be very fascinating fascinating
few months ahead professor peter
matthews thank you very much indeed for
your contribution